you've got to take responsibility for
the energy that you allow in your life I
want you to fend off negativity as much
as humanly possible you know we know so
much more about the brain than we did
just 20 years ago Neuroscience has
taught us incredible things like that
our brains are continuously shaped by
our thoughts and our experiences and you
know this to be true negativity is one
of the most toxic forces on the planet
it's toxic for your brain for your
nervous system and for your ability to
stay motivated do me this favor do not
solicit or listen to the opinions of
people who are notorious for just being
Debbie downers the one mistake that I've
seen people make consistently is they
almost habitually talk to the exact
person who is the most likely to shoot
them down and make them feel like so
don't do that and here's another key I
want you to always consider the source
meaning don't put a lot of stock into
other people's opinions unless they're
actually out there consistently taking
risks and being brave and actually
making things happen I mean if you think
think about it let's say you wanted to
climb Mount Everest would you ever take
advice from someone who's never even
attempted the summit no of course not
that would be crazy so don't take advice
from anyone unless you really think it
through need motivation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best Marie forleo
and my take on her top 10 was a success
enjoy
rule number two be courageous the
courage came from pain
and here's what I mean by that
when I first started out I was trying so
hard to be someone else because I had
this idea in my mind that I probably
formed when I was a little girl about
what a successful businesswoman looked
like how she should act and it was
involved with this again this is like
taking it back I grew up in the 80s
right so I imagined a successful
businesswoman would probably like have
some corner office in a high-rise
building in New York City and have like
a suit with shoulder pads and like wear
high heels and pantyhose and walk around
in a very authoritative like an
authoritative excuse me Authority voice
you know like just like strong and
talking and and also there's a big thing
for me about like intelligence and high
levels of Education I don't really I'm
the first in my family to go to college
and uh I'm from Jersey and I don't
always use proper language I fumble over
my words just like I just did and when I
try to to create content when I first
started off it was so stilted it was so
stiff it had no personality and guess
what it had no results it was terrible
and so the pain of like working so hard
and not having anything work and feeling
like I was banging my head against the
wall and I was like I can't do this I
can't be this professional business
person and the other thing was this I
was so young when I started coaching so
I was 23 years old and I was completely
aware of how ridiculous this was
hell's gonna hire a 23 year old life
coach like I hadn't even lived life yet
I had piles of debt I had failed in all
these different careers like nothing
made sense but I had the heart and so
the big shift came when I had banged my
head against the wall so many times
trying to be like different than who I
was to get people to like me and I was
like this is [ __ ] I can't do this
I'm not built this way I have no filter
if I really if people are gonna like
actually want to hire the real me they
need to see the real me and that was the
shift I really had no other choice
because it felt like I was dying a slow
death to try and pretend to be someone
else who I really wasn't rule number
three think like an entrepreneur should
I get a degree with a secure job at the
end of it so little reality check for
you my love those days are over there's
really no such thing as a secure job
anymore
um I think if you take a look around at
what's happening in the world you go
into any Starbucks bucks and you'll see
some lawyers and some stock Brokers
networking out of there who would
totally back me up on this Paige I know
you said you want to start your own
business and that's awesome but for
everyone else even if you don't want to
start your own business hear me on this
entrepreneurship is a mindset that
everyone on the planet needs if you want
to thrive now and in the future the only
people that are going to really make it
in this world are people that'll take
initiative that'll take action and that
think and behave like entrepreneurs and
one of the first and most important
things about that is getting real
comfortable with not giving a flying
fudge what other people think about you
let me take you back in my own life I
was only a few years older than you when
I decided that I wanted to be a life
coach now you got to get this this was
back when no one even heard of a life
coach those words life coach made as
much sense to people as dream farmer or
potato doctor
and exhale
you still getting baked
[Music]
turn your head and cough for me
plus I was 23 years old I mean who in
their right mind would hire a 23 year
old life coach even I was rolling my
eyes at myself the point is don't let
anyone's [ __ ] opinions or judgments
about what you can't do especially your
own stop you from following your dreams
you will never do anything great in your
life if you've got this song stuck in
your head
[Music]
judging eyes
[Music]
Paige you say you want to plan parties
and events so get to it woman don't wait
for people to give you permission or
until you have some degree just find
somebody who needs a party plan and plan
the confetti out of it and then you do
another and then another and then
another and then all of a sudden
Mazel Tov you are a party planner now in
terms of Education I am a hundred
percent for education in fact I always
advocate for people to be lifelong
learners but don't limit your education
to only what you can learn in the
classroom you should consider getting a
job or two with more established event
planners so you can really learn about
the industry from the inside out and
then there's one more thing and this is
my final and perhaps more important
piece of advice you've got to be really
conscious of who you surround yourself
with you got to get rid of everybody
who's negative and all the naysayers so
if that means getting some new friends
definitely do it and you also want to
feed yourself some really positive
things to your mind and your body and
your soul day after day rule number four
frame your dreams frame your dream and
here's what this means we can't become
what we can't Envision so when I say
frame your dream what I mean is I want
you to take a picture of it in your
mind's eye in Vivid specific detail and
then what I want you to do is translate
that picture into words meaning write
down that big unrealistic dream and I
know that you may have heard about the
power of writing things down before but
the truth is most people just don't do
it which is so crazy because the
research is conclusive on this there was
a study done by Dr Gail Matthews that
shows that you are 42 percent more
likely to achieve your goals if you
write them down so what I want you to do
is whip out your journal or hop on that
keyboard and get writing also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five find
your confidence I think that particular
story I was around like seven or eight
years old so I was a young child and it
was a little precocious thing to do so
at that age the only thing I could
potentially attribute it to and this is
you know pure speculation is a natural
knowing I think that Divine connection
that we all have to something greater
than ourselves
um I feel in many ways like part of my
life is to Simply Be A Channel and to
listen and then to speak and share and
so the confidence and certainty I also
want to say this I feel like I
oftentimes embody radically
um opposing things at the same time so
while a lot of people may watch our
videos or even read the book or see my
newsletters or social and be like oh my
gosh she's so confident I need to be
real I'm also terribly filled with
self-doubt I'm also a person that
questions myself I'm also a person that
sits back and goes like I don't know is
this any good like I don't think it's
any good to you guys are you gonna
really like this so both of those things
can coexist I think that once I've had a
chance to Grapple with something for a
little while and also like road test it
meaning I've had a chance to play with
people use Concepts in real life work
with them coach with them see how things
actually come out how it impacts them
and helps them create results then the
confidence builds quite naturally so
that happened for me when I started as a
coach again I knew internally this is
what I wanted to do but I was very aware
that I was like I don't know crap right
like I have to build up that track
record over time same thing with like a
program like b-school I am very
confident when we go into our we only
open it you know once a year when we go
into our promotional period I get really
fired up vision and it's not false
bravado it's because I'm like I'm
graduated 64 000 people and I've
literally been approached in grocery
stores from women who were on the verge
of homelessness who now run multiple
six-figure businesses and they tell me
like their children's education are
completely funded so when I get fired up
about anything like again about this
book I'm like no y'all I've Road tested
this please For the Love of All Things
holy just give it a try you don't have
to believe it try it before you deny it
though because this is good so I think
um any confidence that you detect one I
just want to underscore it was born from
terrible insecurity that I still carry
around with me now and a lot of
self-doubt anytime I'm starting
something new or I'm stretching into a
new Zone and then the confidence side
just comes from also I've been doing
this now for 20 years like starting in
1999 and it's now 2021. you just I think
that's one of the best things about
maturity and that's one of the best
things about age is like you're like
I've been around the block a few times
and I've seen a couple things and I've
fallen on my face so it's all gonna be
okay and I think probably one of the
other things again not to push it but
Vision I know you and I are both such
fans of books you know one of the
byproducts of adopting the belief that
everything is figureoutable is what I'd
like to call remarkable resilience
remarkable resilience and also a bit of
Courage because
this belief this notion that everything
is figureoutable is so a part of my
cellular DNA that I literally feel
Unstoppable not Unstoppable in the sense
that everything's gonna go my way
because it certainly does not and not
Unstoppable in the sense that I'm like
better than anybody else but Unstoppable
in this sense that if there is something
that I want to learn or experience or
achieve or help bring about I am 100
certain that if I'm committed to that we
will figure it out we will find a way or
we will make a way and when you have
that core belief embedded in you which
is what we teach you how to do in the
book it shifts everything because look
at how much our World Vision is filled
with uncertainty and filled with fear
and uncertainty that's natural right we
kind of kid ourselves into believing we
have some sense of control but when you
have this Bedrock belief that everything
is figure outable when you believe in
yourself that much all of a sudden
you're able to to stand in the tornado
of uncertainty because you know without
a shadow of a doubt that whatever comes
down the pike no matter how hard it gets
no matter how much you cry no matter how
much pain or suffering or confusion or
doubt there is you are going to rise and
you will make it through you know it
doesn't cost you anything not to believe
in yourself excuse me it costs you
nothing to believe in yourself but it
costs you everything not to so number
six set your priorities so many things
in life can feel urgent but they're not
so a few examples checking email
answering calls or texts even from
clients and social media
urgent things demand our attention now
and they can get really addictive
because we all want to feel wanted now
many of us also like a little hit of
drama and adrenaline which email and
social and tax and things like that
happily deliver and finally things that
are Urgent often relate to other
people's goals not our own but important
things are different important things
are quiet there's no alarms there's no
drama important things often relate to
our own goals and dreams not other
people and unfortunately it requires us
to be self-starters and important things
are often easy to blow off hey Marie are
we still hanging out today or she's busy
sorry okay I'll hit you up tomorrow see
where you're at we'll see we'll see
about that
yeah uh we have stuff to do
um the first order of business let's
check Twitter right yeah now Angela I
know you got clients to attend to and
work that pays the bills and sometimes
yes that is urgent however you do have
enough time to create your art and reach
your goals as long as you work on what's
important first and save what's urgent
for a little bit later here's how to do
this now before you get going each day I
want you to take a look at your to-do
list and you're going to Mark each task
with either an i or a u i is for
important and U is for Urgent and then
work on all the eye stuff first and save
the use stuff till later now you gotta
remember the Urgent stuff is always
going to get done because it has to but
this method ensures that your important
tasks don't fall to the Wayside and
unless somebody is seriously hurt or
your house is on fire if something
urgent tries to take your attention
ignore it until your important work is
done for the day rule number seven aim
for more one of the biggest challenges
that most of us go through when we're
starting to explore spirituality and
discovering the whole idea of being
super grateful for what you have is we
can feel guilty about wanting more it's
almost as if oh I really have to just
you know be okay with everything I have
now which is great but it's human to
want to create it's human to want to
grow to want to explore to expand and
take in more and I just want to make a
little note here you know wanting more
doesn't always equate to materialism it
doesn't always mean toys you could want
to touch more lives you could want to
expand your ability to love so wanting
more in and of itself is nothing that
you should shy away from and I
absolutely believe with my heart and
soul that you can be extremely grateful
for what you have and go balls to the
wall with your dreams so I have a few
strategies to share with you that will
help you accomplish this
in my lovely book called make every man
want you how to be so irresistible
you'll barely keep from dating yourself
which by the way we're going to give you
a free audio download Missy just because
you asked such a great question I talk
about a concept called This Is It
this is it really means that you treat
this moment like it's the most amazing
moment of your life you look around in
your world and you just make it the best
it can possibly be so in short wherever
you're at that's where the party is so
if you find yourself standing in line at
a bank and there's a really long line
and everyone else is cranky this is it
this is your moment so you're gonna
party with it you're gonna hang out
you're gonna have a great time talk to
people on the line really appreciate
where you're at but that doesn't stop
you the whole this is it mentality
doesn't stop you from having Big Dreams
that you're also going to pursue so it's
a matter of just finding that balance
but you can absolutely do it and don't
let anyone tell you that uh you're
ungrateful for what you have if you have
big dreams and Ambitions so one more
little note and it's about complaining
this is a great way to just basically
check yourself before you wreck yourself
Chickity chickity check yourself before
you wreck yourself if you catch yourself
complaining you've slipped out of the
modality of being grateful for what you
have and it's going to be really hard to
really attract great things or be really
ambitious or have the energy you need to
achieve those big dreams so use
complaining as a bit of a barometer if
you find yourself saying oh this sucks
my current client sucks my boyfriend
sucks
not so good stop it don't beat yourself
up but just get back into the Grateful
mode and keep kicking ass towards your
dreams rule number eight take risks
first things first if you don't make the
change right now you're right you will
pass along all that self-doubt to your
kids if they see you as someone who's
not willing to take risks as someone
who's not going to go for their dreams
you're going to wind up creating your
own family of realist and what I mean by
that is people who are unwilling to go
for their dreams unwilling to be
unreasonable and here's the thing
Kristen as you know sometimes the best
things in life come when we're being
unreasonable on the other hand if your
kids see you taking action and going
after your dreams and being willing to
embarrass yourself every once in a while
they're gonna get the message that it's
safe for them to take risks and to go
after their dreams instead of just
dreaming about them here's the other
thing about what's missing from your
life Kristen what's missing is fun just
because you're in a slump it doesn't
mean that you've outgrown your house or
your marriage marriage or a job all it
means is that you've outgrown your
tolerance for leading a boring ass life
we human beings need to be creative we
need the adventure and the excitement
and the variety that comes from creative
Endeavors and when I was reading your
question that little line that you have
about dancing that you wish you could
dance you wish you could sing tells me
that you are creatively malnourished you
are starving right now and look you
don't have to go audition for X Factor
or do anything crazy like that you can
just start singing in your shower if you
want or you can take dance breaks at the
office I'll give you an example for my
own life I am a bit of a closet hippie
and in the past year I've been starting
to go to drumming circles I have no idea
what I'm doing but I love it sure I
could have let the fear of looking
stupid stop me but when that stopped me
before number nine deal with criticism
do not give anyone the power to make you
feel worthless nobody as Eleanor
Roosevelt famously said no one can make
you feel inferior without your consent
and there's no place that this is more
true than with criticism now here's an
exercise that I want you to try
Anne-Marie it's called give your critics
the mic so not literally on the stage
but give them a voice on the page
meaning in your journal or on a legal
pad or on a computer wherever you like
to write privately I want you to go off
on yourself so write out the exact words
you think it would crush you to hear so
what could anyone say about you that you
would consider bad would they say you've
got a weak voice that you're too old to
be doing this that your songs are just
bubble gum pop drek that you're pitchy
got that one from American Idol would
they say you're a wannabe Katy Perry or
a poor man Stevie Nicks if you've
already heard hurtful things you can
include those then take a deep breath in
and out and read it to yourself or if
you've got a creative soulmate who just
gets it you can read it aloud to them
then boom the worst that anyone could
say about you you've already said you've
faced it now I want to be clear the
point of this is not to trash your
self-esteem it's to bring your fears out
into the light because when you do that
they lose all of their power just like
the boogeyman that shadow in the corner
you thought was a big scary ghoul turns
out to be a freaking coat rack I'm the
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is be consistently
consistent most of us struggle with
being more consistent in some part of
our lives and it's really worth working
on because the rewards of being
consistent are huge so that being said
here are five secrets to help you be
more consistently consistent number one
is keep your eye on your why in order to
really stay connected to what you're
doing over the long haul you have to
have a clear compelling vision in for
what you're trying to achieve and know
why you want to do it so for example
it's a lot easier to keep saving
consistently if you're saving for
something important to you like your
first house or once in a lifetime trip
you know when I think about marietv this
is a big commitment and we're in our
fifth season and it's not easy to keep
doing this week after week but I am
committed because I'm clear on my why
this show is really the soul of my brand
and it's the primary way that I get to
make a difference to as many people as
possible around the world and that's
really important to me so that's my why
and it is always in my eye number two is
pick your battle now notice I didn't say
bat tells I said battle so I want you to
pick one thing and just stick with that
the reason why is that we human beings
have limited capacity when it comes to
willpower and discipline in fact studies
show that doctors recommend you do not
try to do something like quit smoking
and quit sugar at the same time or
you're going to fail at both and I tend
to agree so pick one thing and once you
really make that a habit and you win
that battle then you can add on
something else number three is schedule
it the late Stephen Covey said this and
it is a major major secret to
consistency don't prioritize your
schedule schedule your priorities so
this subtle distinction is so important
when you're trying to make something
consistent in your life you want to
really build your whole life around it
rather than trying to fit it in you know
when it comes to marietv the reason that
this gets done so consistently is that
we schedule it and we build our entire
year around it so everybody who works on
marietv we have these dates for the year
they are sacred they're non-negotiable
and this is gonna happen come hell or
high water
hey it's Marie forleo you're watching
marietv the place to be to create a
business in life you love these days q a
Tuesday
keep rolling
number four is ignore your feelings now
this is probably the only time you're
gonna ever hear me say this but when it
comes to developing consistency it's
pretty darn important to ignore the
voice in your head that says well I
don't feel like it I mean anytime you're
trying to be consistent at something
worthwhile like working out or
meditating or painting or whatever it's
guaranteed you're gonna hear that voice
when I don't feel like it I mean I hear
that voice all the time there are some
days as much as I love what I do I don't
feel like going to work I don't feel
like doing much of anything but I've
trained myself to override that whole
voice in my head because I know the
power of consistency now if you've been
consistent with something for a long
time or you're just clear that whatever
you're up to you're just done with it
that is fine you can totally pay
attention to your feelings close that
chapter and move on however if you're
still trying to develop consistency see
and the deeper part of you knows you
really do want to keep going please For
the Love of All Things holy ignore your
feelings you can tell them bye Felicia
bye Felicia
number five is catch that wagon so don't
have an All or Nothing mindset don't
think that if you miss one day
meditating or you miss one workout that
you're a total failure when it comes to
falling off the wagon that's fine and
you probably will we all do this is
where I think you're getting tripped up
though I think you're spending so much
time beating up on yourself that you
fell off the wagon that the wagon is
just leaving into the distance and
you're not getting back on it so make
sure you run and catch that wagon and if
you need a little extra inspiration
remember this tweetable
I worked so hard to get my business off
the ground and I was often working seven
days a week you know not just coaching
like that was a portion of what I did
but to keep a roof over my head it was
bartending it was waiting tables it was
like being a personal assistant cleaning
people's toilets whatever I needed to do
in order to pay my rent you know put
food on the table and actually continue
to grow the business so I basically
developed a habit of working non-stop
and formery TV oh yeah like getting the
business off the ground like I worked
sidekick business coach who did like
dance instructions you did everything I
was a Nike Elite Dance athlete I you
know taught anywhere from like three to
seven classes a week at Crunch Fitness
some of them were choreographed some of
them were Basic Fitness I had the
coaching clients I was doing the content
and I was bartending and waiting table
so I had developed this
habit of non-stop work because that was
what was necessary at that time New York
yes yeah I'm always focused on the long
game I think these days a lot of people
want insta results they want to be
Instagram famous they want to have like
a billion dollar business overnight and
if you're just starting out you've never
run a business you've never created
content you've never sold marketed built
a team done any of these things before
to expect instant results it's immature
it's unrealistic you're never going to
get there and some of the people I
admire most in the world no matter what
their craft is dude they're in it for
the long game they're not sitting around
going like you know why can't I get
higher conversions by tomorrow it's like
that's not how this works man and if
you're looking for that type of result
it's just like I'm not interested in
hanging with those kind of people I
think we get better over time I think
you have to really be patient I think
people have to understand especially
when it comes to any so-called like
glamorous type career or people maybe
things that people perceive are
glamorous whether it's something like
what you and I do an athlete an
Entertainer do you know what ninety
percent of the work is grunt work
that's what it is it's unglamorous
sometimes people like I want to see what
you do more I'm like you want to see
what I do more I'm sitting with a messy
bun in my sweatpants sometimes not
showering for three goddamn days because
I'm hammering [ __ ] out that's what I do
I love it but if you're not willing to
put in that kind of work you're not
going to get the outcomes on the other
side what would you regret if it's 20 30
we're doing this again sitting here and
you're like I'm really upset at myself
because I didn't do this in my personal
life in my business my health my family
the world yes I would say the only thing
I could foresee at this moment not
regretting is not continuing to take
that quality time with people I love
that would be the thing that if for
whatever reason I started making
justifications right well this
opportunity is so amazing so I gotta go
here and do this that would be the only
thing to be super transparent with you
yeah because looking back
on these past 10 years the quality time
with people that I love
is everything and I know this so
viscerally in my body is that we're not
going to be here forever and we never
know when the people that we love Gone
Gone
and so for me there is nothing more
important than maintaining and enriching
and deepening those personal relate like
friend relationships Josh my family like
making sure that I show up as fully as
possible and not letting anything take
me off track from that because it's you
know I having not had money and you know
starting with like tons of debt and
building everything from the ground up
and now being in a different position
it's like I can see so clearly the
success on an exterior level like that's
amazing and I'm grateful for it but
nothing can make up for not having a
sense of love in your life and not
having people that you care about and
that you're invested in so there's
nothing that I could strive for or reach
for that's going to be more important
than this you had a quote about this and
you said beliefs are the hidden scripts
that run our lives and that's one of
those if you could get people to really
internalize the fact that right now your
whole life is being dictated by the
beliefs that you have yes how do you
help people unwind those beliefs how do
you help them replace them with more
powerful beliefs because that is like a
layer of the operating system that is so
wildly underappreciated yeah that that's
almost always where I start with people
yeah it has to be I think for all of us
I think the first thing for us to go to
is that recognizing that beliefs are a
choice and every choice can be changed
yes so beliefs are a choice and every
choice can be changed and people react
like you're crazy when you say that
um you know I haven't floated that out
enough in a big enough audience to see
people like
I don't believe it I'm dying to know how
people respond well let's see because I
I really think people think that beliefs
are recognition of Truth
and that to try to change your beliefs
is to try to deny the truth in someone
well I mean for anyone watching whoever
believed in Santa Claus
right like you believed things I'm
certain that I know I have like you
believed things when you were younger
even if you weren't a child if you were
a teenager or you were a young adult
that now
experience or wisdom or something has
shown you no that's not actually the
truth anyway my point is this we
collectively have believed things both
individually and as a society over time
that we've changed our beliefs so I
think that that is proof positive that
our beliefs are a choice and those
choices can indeed be changed you know
obviously there is the phenomenon known
as confirmation bias which is the
brain's um just it tends to reinforce
what we already believe and then ignore
information consciously or
subconsciously that doesn't match what
we already believe which is often why
whenever we're having conversations
about really um delicate topics like it
could be about gun control or
Reproductive Rights or race and they
just evolve so fast because people
hunker down in their belief bunkers and
they're unwilling to see another point
of view but I do hold fast to the back
that all beliefs are a choice and
choices can be changed and here's what
else is cool
um you know this because you're so
immersed in the world of personal
development you're someone who is so
committed to learning and growth
over the years I've read more personal
development notebooks than you can like
just shake a tree at and oftentimes part
of the exercise is like you have to go
hunt down all of your limiting beliefs
right so if you want to become this
powerful person and be the best that you
can be you need to find every single
limiting belief and then change it and
do all these different things here's
what I realized when writing this book
you actually don't need to do that
I have a time saving tool because
everybody needs to save some time and to
make this really effective and efficient
if you adopt the belief that everything
is figureoutable and you take that on
for yourself you don't need to go
hunting down all your limiting beliefs
because that one thing is like the
master key that handles everything below
it it's almost like flipping a switch in
your Consciousness where then everything
else becomes possible so let's say if
you're like oh everything is figure
outable you bump bumped into something
in your relationship that feels like
it's problematic you're like oh I could
figure this out you don't need to go
necessarily looking for all those
limiting beliefs you may eventually
uncover them and that's cool you can
kind of clean them out but you don't
have to do all this front end work adopt
this one it's like the master key and
it'll help you achieve anything you want
for the rest of your life this is not
like hype I'm dead serious on this I
think one of the biggest ways that all
of us can hold ourselves back is
listening to that nasty little lie
inside our head that says I'm not ready
yet I don't have enough experience I
don't have enough credentials who am I
to do X Y or Z and then we just delay
delay delay and before you know it
months if not years have gone by and we
haven't made any real progress you know
this was true for me you know when I
started my coaching career one of the
things I discovered was that I just
didn't want to be a coach I've never
really fit a traditional mode and from
doing all the personal development work
to train myself to be the best coach I
could be I realized I have other
passions I love spirituality I love
writing I love digital business which
was very new in the early 2000s and I
also love hip hop and dance yeah and so
when I was prop 25 I finally gave myself
permission to go take my first official
dance class I never had an official
class as a kid I never took ballet or
did any of that stuff I just moonwalked
across my mom's floor right and just
loved hip-hop music but starting in the
dance world at 25 sounds odd but you're
kind of over the hill yeah because most
professional dancers have been doing it
since they popped out of the womb right
and by the time they're 17 18 they're
going on tour with the hottest artist of
the day
so the reason I'm telling the stories it
relates to start before you're ready so
I'd finally gotten up the gumption to go
start taking classes my teachers told me
they're like you're pretty good you
should try and teach and by the way this
was in a gym environment so Crunch
Fitness in New York City that's where I
was taking classes because I could
afford it and I started becoming a
substitute hip-hop dance teacher and
again I didn't know what the hell I was
doing I just felt like I was out of
place but here's what happened that's
crazy one of my first dance classes that
I ever taught solo when I got done with
it this woman walked up to me and I was
still sweating I was trying to catch my
breath and she said you're really good I
was like thank you that's amazing she
said you know I work for MTV and we're
looking for a choreographer slash
producer I think you should come in and
meet my boss now Ed in that moment I was
so green in the dance world I didn't
know what the hell I was doing so my
brain was going I'm not ready for this
yes why couldn't this opportunity come
two or three or four years later when I
know what the hell I'm doing I'm better
prepared I could actually actually show
up and maybe even land this gig but
here's what I realized in my mind I was
like you're already 25 which is over in
the over the hill in the dance world and
the only chance you're ever going to
have to see if this could actually be a
viable career for you is if you do this
so I remember standing outside of the
Viacom building in New York City wanting
to throw up in the trash can because I
was so nervous because I didn't feel
ready but I pushed myself finally got up
to that office I knocked on the door I
just did my best in the meeting and you
know what I got the gig so cool and
here's the thing that one experience of
being hired as a choreographer slash
producer by the way I still didn't know
what I was doing when I was working with
dancers that had 10 times more
experience than I did I was embarrassed
because I didn't know all the terms I
didn't perform at my I did the best I
could do in that moment but there were a
lot of things that I didn't know Naya
naivete did show however my growth and
learning curve man it skyrocketed and
that one experience changed the entire
trajectory of my career it led to me
eventually becoming a Nike Elite Dance
athlete one of the first in the world it
led to Fitness videos choreographing
commercials for Nike and Reebok and all
of this stuff that would have never
happened if I didn't start before I was
ready yeah that like just devastating
sense of loss
it's pretty crazy how fast that'll snap
you out of some [ __ ] oh it will snap
you out of some [ __ ] and it will
stop you from being in a temper tantrum
and you can use that same notion again
some people might say this is incredibly
morbid I say it's incredibly inspiring I
say if you can use it to wake yourself
up out of that Slumber of staying in
your temper tantrum or being pissed at
your parents or pissed at your friends
or pissed at someone who again if you
can see them as an innocent doing the
best that they possibly could with
whatever tools and understanding and
beliefs and thoughts they had in that
moment you can find a way to transcend
to reconnect to your heart and to be
that love that you really are and then
in the company
um I don't know if I've ever told you
this story but uh one day I was in New
York and I was having like a really bad
PMS craving for carbs I was just like I
was like mama needs some carbs and I was
feeling like a croissant and there was
this great little French bakery around
the corner that I'd never been to and
I'm like I'm gonna go get my croissant
right now so I roll up to this little
French Bakery and on the window there
was like this handmade sign that said
you know off for vacation back you know
July 18th and it was like this two-week
thing wow you're like what and I was
like wait wait what the business you
need to be here yes and yet there it was
empty and this simple little like
hand-drawn sign and in that moment Louis
I had this notion I was like wait a
minute I'm running this digital company
I have all of these amazing beautiful
gorgeous Souls that I work with and
we're producing content once a week
every week non-stop when do we ever take
a break and the advantage for me like
Josh who worked Works in entertainment
like series sometimes they'll have you
know you watch your favorite series like
I love handmaid's tale I love stranger
things you see 11 or 12 episodes and
wait a year and yes and then they're off
for a little while right and I thought
to myself why do I not have down time
built into my business and this was
about the time when also there was just
a cultural Uprising with like you know
hustle 24 7 and you have to work
Non-Stop and like never take a break and
I'll I'll sleep when I'm dead and I'm
like those are horrible messages for
your health yeah so we decided after I
saw so after I had my croissant craving
I told my director of operation as I
said starting right now we're going to
close the company down for two weeks in
the summer and two weeks in the winter
and in addition to people's already
having their yes their vacation time and
we started that I guess maybe I don't
know five six years ago it might be
wrong on those dates but a good number
of time ago and so our company goes dark
twice a year
and now the company's at a place where
not everyone in customer service takes
off those exact same two weeks so they
stagger so that we can take care of
people but everyone has two weeks of
dark time two weeks of dark time and
what's great about that is that you
don't get fomo thinking that you're off
and there's all these other things
happening and there's projects moving
ahead and there's these things that you
want to be in on but you're like feeling
that tension because the rest of the
company is moving ahead and you're
trying to relax so it's been a game
changer for us it was kind of
interesting when we were creating the
book and started selling it actually
into foreign markets they're like well
how are we going to define this word
everything is figure outable because it
doesn't translate into other languages
and I was like okay it is achievable it
means that something is possible we
started playing with all these words but
I think
um to answer the second question of how
this phrase came about I'm taking it
back to Jersey taking it back to the 80s
and taking it back to my mom who is like
this interesting character so she's
about five three she looks like June
Cleaver and she curses like a truck
driver
she grew up in the projects of Newark
New Jersey to two alcoholic parents and
she learned by necessity how to stretch
a dollar bill around the block like five
times and she promised herself that when
she got older she would find a way to a
better life
so cut to me growing up in this
Italian-American home there's like you
know plastic covered couches very
working class and one of my Fondest
Memories was me and my mom sitting at
the kitchen table and cutting out
coupons so because frugality is her
number one thing in life right she loved
teaching me all the different ways that
we could save money
and she also introduced me to this idea
of proofs of purchase do you remember
those from yes so if you like save up
um the fact that you bought x amount of
boxes of cereal or whatever and you
mailed in this little piece of the box
that these Brands would send you like a
cookbook or utensils like good stuff for
free and one of my mom's most prized
possessions was this tiny little orange
radio like transistor AM FM it had a
little red and white straw sticking out
of the side that was the antenna and she
got it for free from Tropicana orange
juice and my mom is the kind of person
who's always busy always doing something
and so as a kid I knew the way to find
her was to listen for the sound of that
tinny little radio coming like somewhere
from the yard or in the house so like
one day I was walking home from school
and I heard the radio off in the
distance and as I got closer it was
coming from above which was a strange
kind of orientation and I look up and we
had a two-story house and my mom who's
tiny is perched on the top of the
two-story house like very precariously
and when you're little and you're short
it just everything is Amplified and I
was like Mom I was like is everything
okay like what are you doing up there
and in her very Jersey accent she's like
uh ree I'm fine you know the the roof
had a leak in it I called the roofer he
said it's going to be at least 500 bucks
I said screw that I went to the garage
there was extra asphalt I'm gonna fix it
and I was just like
okay you know that's Mom another time I
came home and I heard the radio like
blaring from the back of the house so I
walked to the back of the house and I
saw the bathroom it was like the door
was cracked open
and as I push the door open the whole
room was filled with dust particles
there was like pipe sticking out of the
wall it looked like a bomb went off I'm
like Mom what are you doing like is
everything okay and she said you know
the tiles had cracks in them and I
didn't want the bathroom to get moldy so
I'm re-tiling the bathroom
now Tom you got to get this again is the
1980s my mom is high school educated
this was pre-internet pre-youtube
pre-google
I never knew like where I would find my
mom or what I'd find her doing but that
radio was always my clue so one day it
was in the fall and in New Jersey you
know the um daylight savings had already
passed so it was dark right and it was
spooky and I went home and it was
totally silent the house was dark which
is very odd for my family
so I walk in and I had that pit in my
stomach that you have when you're
nervous that something's wrong
and I start walking around the house and
I didn't know where my mom was and I
felt like something bad had happened
then all of a sudden I heard these tiny
clicks and Clacks and I followed this
down to the kitchen and I saw my mom
hunched over the kitchen table it was
like an operating room she had like
electrical tape and screwdrivers and in
a dozen or so little pieces her
Tropicana orange was completely
dismantled I was like Mom that's your
little radio what happened are you okay
is it broken and she said oh it's fine
you know the antenna was off and the
dial was not working right so I'm fixing
it and that was the first time I thought
to ask the question that I really needed
to ask all along which was
how do you know how to do so many
different things that you've never done
before yet no one's showing you how to
do them
and she like put down her screwdriver
and she cocked her head and she looked
at me and she's like what are you
talking about it's not that big of a
deal Nothing in life is that complicated
you can do anything you set your mind to
if you roll up your sleeves you get in
there and you do it
everything is figureoutable and I was
like
like just in that moment and I will tell
you this I don't know Tom for sure
whether she said those three words or
that's what my childhood brain heard and
translated because you know how we do
that kind of thing
but that phrase got embedded in my soul
on such a deep level and I just said it
over and over again and then I realized
as I became an adult it's been the
single biggest driving force of my life
like from you know continuing to get
rejected on like sports teams and
cheerleading and going again and again
and like getting out of an abusive
relationship when I was like my first
love to like getting into classes in
college to getting every part-time job
I've ever gotten every full-time job
I've ever gotten getting out of
relationships into relationships
building the entire business like I
still use that phrase every single day
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one-on-one I did
with the amazing Marie forleo check it
out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there most of us exist in
this space of endless comparison the
compare and despair right so we have
either these idealized versions of
ourselves